religion can be an incredibly profitable
business if done right and there's no
better example of this than the vatican
the world's smallest sovereign nation
at just 0.27 square kilometers it is
home to the wealthiest religion on the
planets the catholic church for decades
the catholic church has been haunted by
scandal after scandal after scandal with
more than 1.3 billion members worldwide
it is the second biggest religion in the
world and this entire empire of vast
unimaginable wealth is based off of your
donations
but the catholic church is clever if
people knew just how wealthy they are no
one would continue donating to them
that's why they keep all their true
finances very close to their chest
careful to not let the public ever peer
into the true financial state of the
church that's why in 2021 the catholic
church is winding that apparently
they're low on reserves running a
deficit and are in desperate need of
your donations
when in australia alone they're worth at
least 30 billion dollars
that's more than what starbucks is worth
around the world and thanks to some
simple math we can get a rough estimate
of how much wealth the catholic church
really has
so the catholic church is worth around
30 billion in australia there's around
five and a half million catholics in
australia that means the catholic church
is able to extract an average of around
five thousand four hundred fifty four
dollars per user there are 372 million
catholics in europe the us canada and
australia combined so five thousand four
hundred fifty four dollars per catholic
times 372 million catholics means that
the catholic church has a little over
two trillion dollars in wealth
and that's just from the main western
countries that means the catholic church
is in the same league as companies you
know and love like apple microsoft the
saudi arabian oil company amazon and
alphabet let's say on that two trillion
dollars they're able to get a
conservative return of three percent for
context the stock market typically
returns ten percent two trillion dollars
at just three percent gives them 60
billion dollars every single year
tax-free theoretically of course
but what do they tell the public that in
2018 apparently they only profited a
measly 20 million dollars nowhere near
even 1 billion
and at the center of all of this is the
vatican bank god's bankers
today it's probably better to think of
the vatican as a combination of the
federal reserve an offshore bank and a
hedge fund compared to just being the
headquarters of catholicism
the vatican is the ultimate corporation
that stood the test of time like no
other and this is how it's done
[Music]
even though the vatican has billions of
dollars today it wasn't always this way
at a few points in history the church
was actually pretty close to going
bankrupt they were so deep in debts in
fact this is a very common way people
stay in poverty they have a bunch of
high interest debt like credit cards
where they can only afford to pay off
the interest every month trapping them
in a very vicious cycle but what if
there is a way to take out a loan at a
much lower interest rate use that new
better loan to pay off your high
interest debts so you're left with only
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date well that is where upstart
comes in upstart is a fast simple way to
get an online personal loan to help you
pay off your high interest debts whether
you want to pay off credit card debt
consolidate high interest debts or just
repay personal expenses upstart can help
by giving you a loan that only requires
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff dates so you know exactly how
much you need to repay and for how long
and instead of just looking at your
credit score upstart looks at things
like your income and employment to give
you a smarter rate for your loan and
these loans can be anything between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
you can check your rate in minutes
without affecting your credit score and
once you're approved you could have
access to the funds in as little as one
business day so if you're interested in
finding out how upset can lower your
monthly payments go to upstart.comtrain
right now that's upstart.comtrend
use the link in the video description
below so they know i sent you upside.com
says jaytran thanks to upstart for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
centuries before the catholic church
became a capitalist holding company the
vatican was a secular empire meaning
that its existence wasn't directly
connected to catholicism as it is today
the popes were the kings of the vatican
and they also acted as the supreme
leaders of the roman church in italy
popes believed that god had chosen them
to reign over all the other leaders of
the world during the time of the pope
kings the vatican controlled over 15 000
square miles of land in italy called the
papal states vastly bigger than the tiny
area the vatican city occupies today all
this land was important because building
palaces and running one of the most
luxurious courts in europe was expensive
and what better way to continue your
life of luxury than by taxing the people
you rule over
just like the corrupt government of
today people's taxes in the 6th and 7th
century went to maintaining the
lifestyles of the pope kings and their
sidekicks also known as the cardinals
over time the taxes just weren't enough
for the lavish lifestyle the guys in
charge had come to expect but there was
a problem the pope was already taxing
the papal states charging fees to trade
and do business selling most of the
region's agricultural products and none
of it was enough he needed a new way to
make money fast
around the 6th century the vatican
leadership suddenly had a brilliant plan
they were already selling most of the
papal state's natural resources to make
money but there were only so many grapes
or vegetables to export
but what if the pope and his cardinals
had something to sell that was
incredibly valuable and would never run
out
they would be able to make infinite
amounts of money so the plan was simple
since the pope was god's representative
on earth and he had thousands of members
in his church what if he could sell them
away to reduce the amount of punishment
they would receive for their sins after
all years of penance and fear of
purgatory had made people terrified of
god's wrath so paying just a little bit
of extra money so he wouldn't burn in
hell as long was a very good deal
so the church started selling
indulgences little tickets that promised
god wouldn't punish them too much for
whatever they did wrong small sins were
cheaper to get indulgences for while
bigger sins were obviously more
expensive
even though it wasn't the original plan
indulgences became people's get out of
jail free cards except they actually had
to pay for them it was a cash cow unlike
anything the vatican had ever seen
before sure hundreds of church officials
were abusing their right to sell
indulgences but when millions flowing
into the church treasury who was the
pope to complain after all the
prosperity of the church was god's will
the sale of indulgences went on for more
than a thousand years during this time
the church and the pope got wealthier
and wealthier but then starting with the
1789 french revolution things started to
go downhill
first napoleon demanded millions in
tribute from the vatican each year then
other leaders of europe started taxing
the vatican's money as well the pope
called taxing the vatican the work of
the devil but it didn't change the fact
that the endless streams of money the
pope had been enjoying were quickly
drying up
something had to be done
[Music]
when european states asking the vatican
for more and more money taxes on the
papal states kept going up and like any
19th century state with corrupt leaders
in climbing taxes the people rebelled in
1848 crowd store in the vatican city and
murdered the papal prime minister the
people of the papal states were tired of
being treated as a cash reserve and the
vatican went into massive debts it was
two years behind on bills taxes were
almost non-existent and even the sale of
indulgences had nosedived the pope in
charge i tried appealing to the masses
allowing more freedom of speech and
releasing more than a thousand political
prisoners but it was too little too late
desperate to keep the vatican and the
church going the pope had a difficult
decision to make he would go to the
rothschilds for help yes those
rothschilds being a jewish family
business the pope had to swallow a lot
of pride to get into their debts but his
lifestyle and wealth was more important
than his pride so the rothschilds left
the vatican 50 million francs around 10
million dollars to cover the vatican's
budget for an entire year but then in
1870 the italians invaded rome and
brought an end to the vatican's control
of the papal states even making deals
with heathens couldn't save the vatican
from financial ruin the 15 000 square
miles of vatican control was reduced to
0.17 the thousands of subjects the
vatican could tax have fallen to around
700 people who lived at the courts the
massive papal empire had fallen and
became what we now know today as the
vatican city
forever
[Music]
around 60 italian families stayed loyal
to the pope they were known as the black
nobles the vatican was at a crossroads
and this led to the first ever catholic
investments into secular businesses the
pope started investing money into roman
real estate and luckily he caught the
front end of the real estate boom and
for a while his investments were a big
success most of the black nobles just
followed the church's example and
invested in the same properties as the
pope did and they got rich too but then
in 1887 the property market crashed and
the vatican was back to square one
looking for a new way to make money so
the church started asking for donations
or peter's pence as they called it they
were in the important business of saving
souls and if regular catholic church
members wanted to get in on the
salvation all they had to do was donate
some money to the church and the church
was back in business and started
investing more than ever into secular
businesses and then just like most of
the major global corporations we talked
about before the world wars came along
and the church saw an opportunity to
profit like never before
but i was never a true banker
they are
just as world war 1 broke out a new pope
took control of the vatican donations
plummeted and so did the vatican's
income again and for a while the new
pope tried to get italy to stay neutral
in the war hoping that it would keep
their investments in italy safe but in
1915 the italians declared war on
germany and joined the allies leaving
the pope desperately looking for a way
to keep his revenues up so the vatican
rented one of its properties in rome to
an arms manufacturer that sold to
germany yes the vatican was indirectly
making money selling weapons of war to
the other side of the war when the
public eventually found out about the
arms dealing the church said it was in
complete shock and never knew about what
its tenant was doing but it was all in
vain because by 1933 the vatican was
losing around 100 million lira a year
desperate not to go under the pope
finally gave in and got a real financial
advisor who helped keep the vatican out
of the gutters by making a lot of
diverse investments and the most
profitable time in vatican history was
only just starting when world war ii hit
instead of staying out of politics and
focusing on religion like he did in
world war 1 the pope went all in and
took the german son the vatican had
become friendly with the fascist leader
of italy mussolini and germany seemed to
be a similar choice
and in exchange for their supports the
third reich would deduct eight to ten
percent of catholic german's wages to be
sent directly to the vatican the third
reich was taxing catholics on the
vatican's behalf the church usually had
trouble getting people to pay on their
own free will so automatically taking 10
of all catholics in germany's monthly
wage did a lot to boost the vatican
economy the germans and the vaticans got
so friendly that when the sitting pope
died there were rumors that hitler could
pay 3 million gold reich marks or 12.6
million dollars at the time and pick
whoever he wanted to be the next pope
the new pope although ashley not picked
by hitler seemed happy to keep a good
relationship with germany and even held
a grand reception for hitler's 50th
birthday money was once again flowing
into the vatican city but there was a
new problem all the vatican's
transactions and money was kept in
western banks and europe which meant
that most of it could be traced or even
frozen and it wouldn't be long before
the allies found out just how much of
the church's money was coming from
germany which would mean instant
blacklisting so the pope's financial
advisor came up with a new plan build a
bank in the vatican after all the
vatican is its own country so why
shouldn't it have a national bank so
this bank with this long name or ior was
born it only had one branch inside the
vatican city and it wasn't on anyone's
blacklist which meant it was free from
wartime regulations the new vatican bank
could operate anywhere in the world
without showing profits annual reports
balance sheets or where its money came
from and it only had one shareholder the
pope
now the vatican could take money from
whoever they wanted deposit it into
their own bank and never leave a single
paper trail behind
and it didn't take people long to see
how the vatican bank could be useful to
them from all over europe rich italians
were now depositing their money into the
vatican bank by sending an employee over
the street with a suitcase full of cash
but it wasn't only the italians
eventually the oss which was the
precursor to the cia found out that even
hitler was making regular deposits into
the vatican bank using a swiss bank as a
middleman out of all the clever business
moves we've seen on this channel this
has got to be one of my favorites
[Music]
near the end of world war ii the vatican
was so deep in bed with the germans they
would even take money from the life
insurance policies of jews that were
sent to camps when the families came
asking for the money they rightfully
deserved the insurance companies would
ask to see a death certificate they knew
no one could actually get so they kept
the money and you guessed it deposited
that money into the vatican bank and it
wasn't just the germans in the days of
the italian mafia anyone with drug money
racketeering money or any other illegal
funds could deposit their cash at the
vatican bank and no it can never be
traced and their deposits never made
public the vatican bank became known as
the place to launder or hide your money
and with all that notorious reputation
came a lot of government attention but
instead of closing down the bank forward
to legal or unethical activities the
italian government thought they could
profit too and decided that all the
regional banks owned by the vatican
would have to start paying tax by the
mid 50's the church has 600 million
members and dependent on donations for
most of its money and investments so
when a report came out that the vatican
had 13 billion dollars in liquid
investments the pope quickly corrected
them saying that it was probably closer
to 500 million less than four percent of
the estimate but soon the church would
run into more trouble with donations but
it wouldn't be because of people finding
out just how much money they had
around the late 20th century reports
started going around about how priests
abused children
i'm sure you've seen at least one of
these stories in the news
obviously the idea that the priesthood
that people who were supposed to be the
leaders of the churches were hurting
kids was bad news for donations the
vatican had to do everything in its
power to keep people quiet if the church
admitted to knowing about the abuse it
would be the end of them so by january
2002 the catholic church had already
paid out around 175 million dollars in
settlements to families from australia
to europe instead of apologizing the
pope made excuses which meant even more
lawsuits were filed and even more money
was paid out by 2014 that 175 million
dollars in settlements had turned into
more than 3 billion
donations dropped but as usual the
vatican had a plan
[Music]
in 2013 after the death of the sitting
pope they decided to make a radical
change they would elect a new modern
pope one who would appeal to the masses
promise perform and actually make it
seem like he's making change so pope
francis took power and set out to fix
the church's reputation and it worked
[Music]
with the help of a pope who could appeal
to the masses and make it seem like he
really cared about the people the
vatican was able to make everyone
conveniently forget about what they had
done to get so much money and power in
the first place which leads us to today
where the church has more than 1.2
billion followers based on my
estimations at the beginning of this
video they have around two trillion
dollars in wealth and their number one
call for donations is yet again that
they're on the verge of bankruptcy even
though one catholic official in new york
city alone is the largest landowner in
manhattan proving once again that when
you have just the right combination of
guilt fear and the promise of eternal
life religion can be one of the most
lucrative businesses in the world
[Music]
this is how the vatican really operates
and why this is probably the first time
you're hearing about most of this other
empires like the vatican are exactly the
same they're never going to publicly
review their motives and intentions so
you can learn from them but that is
exactly what we're doing here going over
all the things they'll never be able to
teach you in business school however
this video was definitely pushing the
boundaries of what is monetizable on
youtube you know talking about germans
and world war ii and stuff that's why we
have a new private feature length 40
minute plus documentary series where we
break down how the world really works
that will never be released to the
public we already have one now called
monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply which our private
members loved and word on the street is
the next one is either gonna be on
everyone's favorite cia mind control
program mk ultra or maybe we'll have one
on our friend whose first name starts
with a j and last name starts with a e
wink wink no promises on that one just
yet
all you have to do if you want to watch
the monsanto dock and all the future
ones is click the join button below
right now right next to the subscribe
button if you don't see the button
there's a link in the description and
unlike an mba it's not gonna cost fifty
five thousand dollars to 161 thousand
dollars nope just five dollars a month
why is this paywall because if i posted
these publicly most would be demonetized
and i would probably get cancelled which
will result in no free videos whatsoever
the free videos are gonna keep coming at
the same rates so nothing is changing
you can preview all the private
documentaries out there already with
this link below whether you're a member
or not
and guys i'm currently recording this as
i'm recovering from being sick so sorry
if my voice sounds weird
[Music]
you